[Musique]
loana merci d'être là
merci beaucoup loana merci loana d'être
là alors on a plein de choses à te dire
je vais te dire déjà merci d'être là en
entrant dans le loft c'était quoi ton
objectif à l'école ah ouais c'était
juste de faire une à une aventure avec
des amis c'est ça donc après ça devient
la folie temarii star était la plus
grande star de téléréalité germain est
épié c'est la plus lourde est la
première c'est la première évidemment il
ya après exactement les mêmes pas parce
qu'effectivement rappelez-vous le
déferlement elle remonte l'avenue de la
grande armée très vite tes la coqueluche
des français
les français adorent été sollicités de
partout en 2009 sortira une
autobiographie miettes qui se vendra
plus de cent mille exemplaires la
musique voilà tu sors en 2001 le single
comme je t'aime qui se hissera 18 plaide
18e place du classement singles en
france
jean paul gaultier s'intéresse à toi et
te fait défiler pour ses nouvelles
collections oui c'est des souvenirs
incroyables pour toi tu deviens même
styliste et imagine ta propre ligne de
vêtements oui je tape dans la presse il
ya eu des milliers des miniers deux
magazines avec en couverture
loana et voilà on aimerait la gloire
c'est la chute libre a été la fiq libre
mais au fil des années sa sortie du loft
l'euphorie retombe et tu te retrouves de
moins en moins sollicités c'est pas que
j'ai été de moins en moins sollicités
c'est que c'est moi qui ai fait la
bêtise d'être mal entouré est de -
répandre aux sollicitudes c'est ça alors
un moment tu as vraiment plongé dans la
drogue
oui c'est ce que tu dis bien sûr fait
passer comment ça s'est passé parce que
avant de rentrer dans le loft
non mais ils connaissent se connaître se
succèdent sauf que tu connaissais la
drogue est ce que tu étais donc dans ses
délires ou pas du tout non je n'étais
pas du tout mais j'avais 23 ans c'est
pas le loft comme on dit qui m'a fait
plonger dedans ça a été les moissons
rencontre j'avais 30 ans je suis tombé
je tends donc voilà et donc derrière
qu'est ce qui se passe il paraît que tu
disais tu dis à un moment que tu prenais
de la drogue au petit déjeuner oui c'est
donc l'homme kaka
qui est alcoolique et qui boit son verre
d'alcool matin au réveil et ben moi je
prenais de la drogue au matin en éveil
tu prenais quoi la cocaïne
c'est à dire donc le matin au réveil tu
te réveiller il faut que je prenais j'en
prenais je prenais un trait way jusqu'au
soir donc comment toute la journée et on
trouve la journée way et entendre dedans
comme on tombe dans l'alcool donc les
gens ne font que boire et je suis tombé
dans la drogue comme on tombe dans port
d'une aide et la drogue comme ça pour
oublier pour oublier ça ne devient pas
didier quoi pour oublier les gens qu'il
ya autour de moi et qui me faisait du
mal c'est qui ces gens qui êtes autour
de toi qu'est ce qui s'est passé après
le loft
ça a été longtemps après le loft
parce que pendant dix ans j'ai j'ai été
comme ça donc c était que dix ans plus
tard après le loft que tu tombais dans
ses addictions la halle puis sombré dans
l'alcool sont bien la drogue
je voulais oublier je vous ai oublié ma
vie tous les oublier ta d'oublier ma vie
qui me convenait pas oui tu as gagné
beaucoup d'argent
j'ai gagné beaucoup d'argent et des
centaines de milliers d'euros oui ça se
chiffre à combien à peu près presque à
un million un million d'euros pas plus
non un million de rouille
forcément tu as tout cramé j'ai pas tout
cramer justement rien n'est pensé on a
cramé à ma place à tous crins matin
passent mais la drogue c'est comment tu
quittes qu'ils fournissent et cette
drogue mon petit copain a été dure à
l'époque à d'accord ça aide pas non non
ça être pas le disent haut et c'est ça
fait partie dicks des fréquentations qui
tombe fait plonger actuellement bien sûr
ce n'est pas quelqu'un qui me disait de
ne pas en prendre c'est quelqu'un qui me
disent il fut justement d'en prendre
pour pas que tu t'en sors ton fait pas
que je m'en sas et j'étais beaucoup plus
manipulable c'est ça ces jours là tu les
as connu à la sortie du loft
non je n'ai pas connu à la s'intitule
ateliers se connu beaucoup plus tard il
est intéressé par toi pourquoi il
voulait en bout la tour d'argent ils
voulaient pas rouler à mon argent il en
voulait à ma célébrité il en voulait et
quand tu dis que c'est pas toi lui
l'avait fait à 23 ans je suis tombé dans
mes addictions à peu près vers mes 30
ans
donc c'est atteint après le loft donc je
les ai pas rencontrés après le jeu je
les ai rencontrés en arrivant à paris
et quand tu dis on a dépensé l'argent
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
il est pas si vous ce million dans les
poches de mon ex et de ma mère de ta
mère c'est ce qui s'est passé que tu
aimes bien elle elle donner les
informations à mon ex de mes codes de
carte bleue ce genre de choses donc une
cuisse est dépensé et pour quoi faisait
ça par méchanceté
tu as porté plainte contre ta maman hier
oui mais pourquoi ta maman faisait ça
vous êtes vous êtes vous entendiez bien
avant ouais on s'entendait bien avant
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé qu'est ce
qui a fait que je sais pas elles t'ont
veux je sais pas dissous elle donne
était code de carte bleue à ton ex
dealer
non il était pas d'hier alors d'accord
c'est frais de covin c'était l'autre là
sinon oui j'étais un autre avant ne
l'était pas non d'accord et ta mère tu
essaies discute avec elle voit un petit
peu ouais ce que tu as dit elle me dit
que c'est pas vrai mais mes huit cent
mille euros
il nous reste dix mille à l'enduro rhume
il me reste dix mille euros d'un volet
800 kg on m'a volé 800000 euros et est
ce que tu avais des dépressions quand tu
étais dans le loft déjà oui oui déjà
oui oui l'agglopole arrêté c'est une
maladie qu'on a depuis toujours d'accord
alors bien sûr que je l'avais elle était
moins importante et elle s'est accentuée
de par le fait que j'ai pris justement
ses addictions
comment tu as fait pour t'en sortir je
me suis dit à un moment qu'il fallait
que fallait que ça change je faisais 49
kg c'était il ya plus de dix ans de ça
c'était c'est pas maintenant et je
faisais 49 kg je mangeais plus je
dormais plus
et donc il ya un moment donné où on se
dit il faut arrêter et et j'ai voulu
arrêter j'avoue vraiment que ça a été le
moment le plus pénible dommage il y
aurait alors cette descente aux enfers
elle n'en finit plus un moment tu vas
penser au pire
oui et en 2007 qui tente de mettre fin à
ses jours en prenant trop de médicaments
oui
qu'est ce que tu t'es dit ce jour là tu
t'es dit je m'en sortirais jamais je
veux arrêter je suis exactement je m'en
sortirais jamais j'ai voulu mourir donc
on regarde le soleil pour la dernière
fois on fait un câlin à mon chien pour
la dernière fois et on prend des
médicaments pour en finir avec la vie je
n'essaye et pas qu'une fois et c'est
cette fois c'est cette fois que je suis
là et fait deux arrêts cardiaques et
3com a way sur une durée de quatre ans
je m'en suis sorti parce que j'ai une
bonne étoile et aujourd'hui voilà qui tu
peux avoir confiance personnes encore et
encore la fois tu encore envie de te
battre tu es encore jusque là tu es sur
un nouveau départ et lycées ouais mais
tu as peur de l'avenir
j'ai moins peur de l'avenir j'avais peur
encore il ya quelques mois oui ce que tu
te dis que le plus dur est passé
le plus dur est passé on est jeune on a
envie d'avancer d'un j'ai envie
d'avancer ouais ça se sent et je le sens
à l'intérieur de moiry envie d'être
heureuse j'ai envie d'être heureuse mais
je crois que je mérite